okay I mentioned this story before and I
mentioned it earlier today Roy Moore is
an absolutely bonkers Looney Toons
Alabama Republican he is a guy who
previously said that the First Amendment
only applies to Christians he once said
he believes he might one day give his
life to prevent same-sex marriage which
seems like a really stupid way to end up
getting yourself killed so far he hasn't
done that ruin Moore won the Republican
primary for the special Senate election
that's upcoming in Alabama he defeated
Luther strange Donald Trump had backed
Luther strange and then as soon as Roy
Moore won Donald Trump went into his
Twitter history and deleted a bunch of
his tweets that were supportive of
Luther strange as if we don't have those
archived tweets in any case Roy Moore is
now the Republican candidate in that
race and I've been telling you this is
probably the fifth or sixth time I
mentioning this there is a really good
option in Alabama a democratic option in
Doug Jones Doug Jones supports I don't
even know where to start he supports
properly funding public education he
supports working to reduce inequality he
supports access to health care for all
Doug Jones is a solid Democratic
candidate last week I told you that Roy
Moore the Republican in very very red
Alabama was leading by only five or six
percentage points the election is
December 12th you've got to register by
November 27th the big news is that they
now appear to be tied according to a new
Fox News poll and of course you can
decide whether a Fox News poll is
trustworthy or whether we would assume
that the Fox News poll poll would skew
to the right and thus Fox News saying
that the Democrat and Republican in
Alabama are tied means that actually
Doug Jones is ahead 42 - 42 Doug Jones
and Roy Moore are tied 11% are still
unsure in that race now we have to
assume that in a state like Alabama
those unsure voters those undecided
voters are probably going to break for
the
more than four the Democrat just based
on party registration in the state of
Alabama so I don't want to pretend like
Doug Jones is a shoo-in here to defeat a
Republican for the seat public
previously held by Jeff Sessions in
Alabama but what I do want to
communicate to you is that this is
already a huge deal and this is all the
more reason to get involved in this
campaign if you can get involved
financially in this campaign
please do it if you can get involved by
doing get-out-the-vote work in this
campaign please do it this is Jeff
Sessions his old seat it would be huge
to put a Democrat in this longtime red
Senate seat in Alabama Donald Trump won
in Alabama over Hillary Clinton 62 234
right Hillary Clinton lost in Alabama by
nearly 30 percentage points and
according to this Fox News poll the
Senate race is tied in the state of
Alabama Roy Moore is going to try to get
national money okay Roy Moore will be
campaigning for national donations on
hey it's Alabama and Democrats could
take our seat and that will probably
work that is going to be an effective
campaigning technique so this is going
to be an uphill battle the tide pole
doesn't represent how difficult this is
going to be and it just so happens that
not only is this any opportunity to take
a red
Senate seat and turn it blue is an
opportunity that Democrats should relish
and should get involved in with Roy
Moore it also happens to be one of the
most vile extreme and disgusting
Republicans out there and and we should
all be working to try to get Roy Moore
to lose this election and by the way the
morale destruction that would take place
if Jeff Sessions is old seat ends up
going to a Democrat in Alabama would be
fantastic I would absolutely love it so
if you have time if you have money get
involved let's help doug jones defeat
Roy Moore in Alabama and you can discuss
that poll as well in our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t let's take a quick
break a lot more coming up on
program today the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as one dollar per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad